[Music]
today's question comes from jason in
alabama he says my wife and i recently
paid off all credit cards and student
loans totaling 32 000
i'm a finance manager for a car
dealership and one of the perks of my
job is that i can buy new and used
vehicles for great prices we have two
auto loans of 40k and 50k we typically
keep a vehicle for a short period of
time and then sell the vehicle to claim
the retail profits we've always made
more than we've paid on or for the
vehicle i'm new to your show and i need
you to tell me if i'm being
irresponsible or is my ability to buy
and sell for profits on vehicles a quote
unique position to use to my advantage
i'm aware that i'm likely to get the
rough talk for having dumb debt and
maybe that is what i need
that's interesting well at least he's
self-aware that helps oh he's dave aware
dave aware that's a whole new level of
self-awareness
wow interesting situation here so
they're 90 000 in debt but he's saying
well dave i'm just flipping i'm just
flip it's like flipping houses what's
wrong with that
very interesting
well
i i can tell you there's there's better
ways to make money uh than on these
depreciating assets and the fact that
he's a finance manager for a car
dealership tells me that he is used to
going into debt helping people go into
debt and he he thinks he's above the
system because he's figured it out he's
making money off the system
but i don't think that will last long
and i i if i'm in his position i'm not
doing it but that's one man's opinion
who does not like debt
yeah
well i mean obviously we're going to
tell you not to do debt son
uh here's the thing you're not
calculating
you have over calculated the profits and
under calculated the risks
that's what you've done
and time will prove me to be true when
you get your freaking head taken off
and i don't know what form it'll take it
could be a pandemic it could be you just
lose your job
and now you've got 90 000 cars
debt
that's scary now are you buying cars and
making a profit on them i don't doubt
that at all i think that's very possible
lots of people around the car business
do that especially right now
it's very possible to do that
so um but but we're not going to use
debt to finance that
if you're asking dave ramsey and george
campbell
because we don't like the risk
associated with it put your family in
peril for the few dollars that you're
making on it and yes you're right you
have rationalized your butt off son i
mean you've figured out every way that
this works in no way that it doesn't
work
and the you know that's what it means by
your risk meter is not working
so
the uh the deal so if he wants to do
this pay cash for the car then flip it
you keep all the profits absolutely so i
would i would get rid of these and then
i would save up money and buy a car for
cash that i can flip and if you want to
roll in and out of cars with cash
and make a profit on them that's cool
let me tell you what will happen when
you do that
you're going to do fewer deals
because when you buy something with
borrowed money
uh you do not analyze it as careful
because it doesn't feel real
when you're buying it with your money
out of your savings account it's
different it's like oh
i'm not sure about this oh
and you have it's a different feeling
right and so what amounts to is you're
emotionally accepting the risk when you
pay cash for it yeah and when you when
you borrow money into anything you don't
think about it as much
it's too easy quote easy payments it's
easy to purchase press hard with that
pin as you're signing there's three
copies you have to get through all the
carbon i mean that's the way you're
thinking it's the only stress involved
and when this market calms down there
may not be much profits to be had at
that point i think if you buy a fifty
thousand dollar car for forty thousand
you're probably always going to be able
to turn it for for a ten thousand a
profit i mean you know and the market's
not going to suddenly change and catch
you there i'm more afraid of a major
change in something else where just
people quit buying cars all of a sudden
for some reason i mean like i mean
pandemic is an extreme example i don't
think we're going to see that again i
hope we don't i've never seen it in my
lifetime anything where it just shut
everything no one's driving anywhere but
the point being what that did was what
the pandemic did for all of us was it it
validated that what we've been teaching
and
so
the big deal jason is this what we teach
you about money works it's the only
system for money
that works in good times and bad times
there are some systems that work only in
bad times and some systems like yours
that work only in good times see debt
only works when debt works when
everything works out the way it's
supposed to perfect that's when it works
but but what it does do is is when
you're stupid is stress tested
and when things aren't going good and
stress comes along you're stupid it'll
you'll go oh my god that's stupid and
you weren't it didn't look stupid
whenever everything's going good stupid
can feel smart
because you're not measuring risk and i
know i've done it i've done it with big
zeros on the end so um i mean how can it
go wrong to buy a rental property if the
renter pays your end
until the renter doesn't pay the rent
and then you still have the rental
property oh by the way not only do they
not pay the rent they go into chapter
13. oh worse than that they're going to
chapter 7. so it's four months before
the federal injunction about you
contacting your
debtor as a creditor you're it's illegal
for you to contact your tenant in any
way while they're in chapter seven until
the court gives you permission
and it can be three four months before
you can even contact them so now where's
your renter that pays the rent so your
stupid just got stress tested
and it was revealed the cracks the
fissures
in the in the the earthquake in the
plate teutonic plate shifted and boom
you get caught and you're like one of
those dinosaur movies you fall into the
volcanic crater the volcanic crater you
know so beware of that so jason we would
tell you yes i would keep flipping cars
but only with cash and that means you
got to get rid of these two
wow we weren't unclear with that we
weren't too rough that wasn't too rough
right there it could have been could
have been rougher
but we're just he's aware
er
ish